[Musik]
und ich begrüße jetzt hubert aiwanger er
ist stellvertretender bayerischer
ministerpräsident und
wirtschaftsminister im freistaat herr
aiwanger wie gut kann denn bayern mit
dem was da gestern beschlossen wurde
umgehend beziehungsweise leben gleiche
der kabinettssitzung
ja es ist jetzt endlich ein fahrplan
erstellt ihr natürlich noch nicht alle
wirtschaftsbranchen zufrieden stellt
beispielsweise die gastronomie vg10 die
ringen die obigen mit uns weiter aber
zumindest diese jetzt mal entspricht die
richtige richtung getan wenn man es auch
zwanzigster april können jetzt alle
läden höfen mit den 800 quadratmetern
eventuell auch mit der vorgabe wie eine
maske zu tragen zwar noch nicht
verpflichtend aber ich würde darauf
drängen dass die leute das tun und dann
eben ab mai auch der friseur das sind
erste schritte die großveranstaltungen
bis ende august völlig dicht zu machen
auch natürlich viele etwas überrascht
das ist die definition was ist die
großveranstaltung da wird man noch
nachjustieren müssen im detail aber wir
haben jetzt zumindest einen groben
planung das ist gut aber bayern wird ja
vermutlich wieder einen leicht anderen
weg gehen zum beispiel bei der
stufenweisen öffnung der schulen und
bestimmter leben werde man etwas
zeitversetzt vorgehen das hat markus
söder jedenfalls gestern angekündigt zum
beispiel der unterrichtsbeginn soll erst
am 11 mai losgehen was verspricht man
sich denn von diesen tagen oder wochen
später in bayern ist nun mal mit am
stärksten betroffen im gesamten
bundesgebiet wir haben die höchsten
infektionsraten und singt es deswegen
etwas vorsichtiger vielleicht als andere
bundesländer die weiter vom schuss sind
an der stelle
wir sind neutral und österreich und
haben es als erstes mit abbekommen und
die schulen würden ja auch als erstes
geschlossen deshalb weil man dort den
größten infektionsherd befürchtete und
insofern ist es nur folgerichtig dass
wir auch mit der öffnung der schulen
etwas hinterherhinken und sagen wir
machen lieber eine woche oder 14 tage
länger zu als es andere für nötig
erachten das ist für die spezielle
bayerische situation durchaus
mir liegt besonders mit blick auf die
wirtschaft da haben sie ende märz in
einem interview folgendes gesagt wir
halten das natürlich nicht monatelang
durch sondern meine einschätzung ist
irgendwann ab mitte april müssen wir
müssen wir die kurve gekratzt haben
wurde das denn jetzt in ihren augen
getan haben jetzt mitte april
ja die kurve kratzen heißt den weg in
die andere richtung einschlagen das
heißt noch nicht völlige normalität und
schon wieder zurück auf start sondern
genau das ist jetzt eingetreten wenn ja
auch sorge von daten als jetzt ist
irgendwann auch mit der brille porto
rotondo geben und wir kratzen jetzt die
kurve in dem wir schrittweise wieder
öffnen und das müssen wir jetzt behutsam
an mit gesundem menschenverstand tun und
ich würde sogar in bezug auf die masken
pflicht noch eins drauflegen wenn wir es
schon dringend empfehlen dann sollten
wir es vielleicht sogar vorschreiben
darüber wie man heute auch in bayern
diskutieren ich wäre dafür dass noch
etwas restriktiver zu fordern um eben
auch gut begründbar hier dann die
geschäfte öffnen zu können und zu sagen
wenn wir schon meinen mit einem mund
nasenschutz können wir infektionen
reduzieren dann sollen wir das bitte
schön auch mit diesem artikel tun der
quasi relativ selbst hergestellt werden
kann aus baumwolle geschneidert und
nicht auf der anderen seite täglich wird
der wirtschaftliche schaden in
deutschland vor fünf bis zehn milliarden
euro in kauf nehmen und die maske nur
empfehlen
das heißt eine dringende empfehlung
reicht ihm nicht aus wie können sie aber
sichergehen dass wirklich jeder dann am
ende so eine maske hat sie haben gerade
gesagt man kann sie selbst schneidern
aber wie wollen sie auch sicher gehen
dass nicht am ende medizinische masken
für den besuch oder den einkauf im
supermarkt genutzt werden und die
medizinischen massen dann letztendlich
nicht in die kliniken in die praxis
gelangen da wo sie natürlich dringend
benötigt werden also wir sind ja jetzt
schon drei vier wochen drin in diesem
corona krisenmodus und jeder hat jetzt
über wochen hinweg diese appelle gehört
hat im internet die möglichkeit sich
eine schneide anleitung herunterzuladen
und es ist ja kein
hexenwerk so eine maske zu schneidern
die österreicher sagen im schlimmsten
fall einen schal umbinden ist besser als
nichts und das ist in meinen augen
durchaus er war musste ist ja auch nicht
beim autofahren tun ich finde etwas spaß
ich wenn jemand alleine im auto sitzen
hat die maske auf das ist wirklich
schade um die maske
aber derjenige der in den supermarkt
dahin geht die halbe stunde was sich
darin aufhält ist ihm das zumutbar
genauso wieder im bus oder in der bahn
neben anderen der kunden sitzt
und wenn er rausgeht kann also wieder
abnehmen der muss ja nicht den ganzen
tag tragen aber wenn wir mit dieser
maßnahme die jeder sich selber
anfertigen kann ja nicht zurecht kommen
dann braucht man wochen und monate lang
die wirtschaft zu spielen
es gibt ja von einigen seiten kritik an
der stufenweisen öffnung von geschäften
unter anderem vom handelsverband
deutschland die abstands und
hygieneregeln die könnten ja auch in
großen geschäften eingehalten werden
sagt er
der bayerische ministerpräsident söder
sagt dagegen sogar eine verkaufsfläche
von 800 quadratmetern halte er für viel
zu groß werden recht ja für mich ist die
maßgabe wie kann ich infektionen
vermeiden
und wenn ich in großen läden genügend
abstand habe von mann zu mann und hat
die maske auf dann ist das mit
sicherheit besser als wenn ich auf
kleinem laden bereich ohne maske darin
stehe also ich sag mit maskierung viel
abstand ist der größere laden mindestens
so begründer wieder kleine laden ohne
maske und darauf müssen wir jetzt eben
abziehen und vernünftige kompromisse
schmieden
die sorge von größeren verkaufsflächen
ist natürlich dass dort letztlich
hunderte menschen drin sind und sich
dann plötzlich doch gewollt oder
ungewollt vor der toilette vor dem
verkaufsraum vor dem ausgang plötzlich
bündeln und plötzlich 50 leute auf 20
quadratmeter stehen ohne dass man vorher
gewollt hatte und wenn weniger leute auf
kleinen lernen die überblickt man
leichter das ist wohl die maßgabe und
hier sind wir gefordert einfacher
vernünftige lösungen hin zu bekommen und
vielleicht sogar größeren läden einen
teil der verkaufsfläche sperren lassen
und sondern macht auch duah nur auf 800
quadratmeter oder
auch immer auf 400 wobei ich durchaus
dafür bin bei den 800 zu bleiben und
nicht runter zu gehen aber das werden
wir heute diskutieren also viel
diskussionsstoff heute noch eine letzte
frage inwieweit befürchten sie denn
einem isolations müdigkeit bei den
bayerischen bürgern
ich sage mal so die ersten wochen war
die bevölkerung sehr überzeugt davon
dass wir nicht die kranken und ich bin
auch überzeugt dass wir richtig
gehandelt haben aber es kommt irgendwann
der punkt wo der bürgers auch ich kann
das nicht monate lang durchhalten und
die infektionszahlen geben uns recht ich
zahlen sind rückläufig und wenn man nach
vier wochen nach sechs wochen deutlich
positive ergebnis sie hat wie jetzt über
vielleicht das schnell ungeduldig aber
nochmal wir können nicht monatelang auf
diesen krisen modus in strengster
bleiben sondern müssen die menschen auch
dafür belohnen dass man eben sich jetzt
zu diszipliniert verhalten hat und dann
eben schrittweise wieder die läden
öffnen wieder zum friseur gehen dürfen
das sind dann auch psychologisch
wichtige muster um eben weiterhin die
krise ja bis zum ende zu begleiten und
vielleicht nur zu akzeptieren dass man
im sommer des lieblings große volksfest
immer noch nicht hat aber vielleicht im
herbst dann wieder dinge hat also
insofern glaube ich dass wir durchaus
jetzt die bevölkerung mitnehmen dürfen
und mitnehmen müssen aber auch nicht
überfordern dürfen sagt hubert aiwanger
vielen dank und grüße nach münchen